Yeah,
would give you stadiums and why
even really contemplating what we're doing.
We're you see the sports team,
it's a,
it's a cooperative and competitive attempt to specify and hit a target and we're
so excited about that.
Probably because of these two part were built physiologically going on hunting
platform,
throwing platform,
right?
I mean human beings can throat and we can throw a punch or throw a ball and
throw a spear and that's a big deal.
That's a big part of what we are.
So Ricardo seeking creatures and so to be precisely for speeches,
to specify the target is specify the target is to have an aid.
They have an aim is to have a purpose and to aid properly institute attain your
purpose at least in principle.
And so partly what we're doing in the future authoring exercises to specify your
purpose with your precise fish.
And so we asked people to,
well here's another thing to contemplate.
We are creatures were built one hunting platform.
We'd like to hit targets as possible that we're good at it.
And then what that also means is that,
well,
if we aren't good at it and it's,
that's part of what we are,
then if you specify target,
you might be able to hit it.
That's a hell of a thing.
There's a,
there's a statement in the New Testament,
it's quite a strange statement and it's a,
it's a,
it's a suggestion.
The suggestion is that if you knock the door will open that if you ask,
you will receive a new thing.
Well that seems highly likely and well I got to see highly unlikely,
right?
I'm sure that's the way the world is set up.
It's like that is actually the way the world is set up.
It's very strange thing and it's not that surprising if you start thinking
through and stuff,
even after all,
hypothetically through to the world evolution has been working three and a half
billion years to produce you.
And so,
you know,
maybe I could've done a better job.
That's
such a bad job.
So maybe she could have taken your aim.
What of the things that certainly learned as a clinical psychologist once.
Because a lot of the people that I saw who were unhappy with their life say
sometimes they're bigger than that,
and he had him detained what they wanted had been detained in Austin in large
part because they never specified it,
and the probability that you're going to hit a tiny target precisely without
aiming at it,
is serum.
That's not gonna happen so well.
So what would have happened if you would aim at.
That's the question,
how should you best aim?
That's another question.
That's part of what rules for life about the rule for example,
is treat yourself like you're someone responsible for helping.
It's kind of a nice start,
so I can imagine again,
if you're aiming a rifle,
you have to put yourself in a certain physiological state,
right?
What I'm taking some deep breaths and calm down and you want to make sure your
hands are shaking a particularly good,
so forth and put yourself in the right frame of mind and if you're going to take
able with your life,
it's the same thing.
You have to put yourself in the right frame of mind and what's the right frame
of mind and it might be something you can assume that you're actually,
hypothetically a valuable preacher even though you might not think that self is
your soul.
Absolutely knowledgeable about your own flaws insufficiencies,
but independent of that,
you might think,
well,
you can lend yourself a hand and you can do something good for yourself just up
with the goodness of your heart,
you know,
like you might do for someone that cared about.
Now that's actually very difficult for people.
You know,
like most of us love someone or a couple of people or just half heartedly
released,
managed our children.
Well,
you know,
it's going to be fully committed to something,
but generally,
generally we do a pretty good job with our,
with our partners or husbands and wives and a pretty good job with our children.
It's a little more iffy there.
A decent job with parents.
Oh,
you know,
it's 70 slash 30 or whatever,
but maybe you can get elevated more than that with a lot of effort.
But I don't know how good we are about doing that for ourselves.
I would say much less so.
And part of that is definitely the fact that we're very aware of our own flaws
and insufficiencies personally,
you know more about how regine useless you are fundamentally then above anyone
else.
And so that's rather disheartening given that it's disheartening then it's not
so easy to take care of yourself properly,
but he doesn't know him.
He is to me that you really have that,
that right not to take care of yourself.
I think you have a responsibility to take care of yourself as if you're
something of value,
which you are.
And so that's a responsibility.
And so when you filled out the future authoring program,
you're,
you're asked to,
for the sake of experimentation,
the frame of reference,
a frame of reference within which you give yourself the benefit of the delta.
Then there's something about you that might be usefully brought forward into the
world.
And you know,
it's,
uh,
an axiom of arts society that there is something about you that would be
usefully be brought forward into the world because our whole society that's
predicated on the notion of the sovereign individual or even of the dividing
people and we wouldn't have a exceeded political power to each and every one of
us if and would work unless there was actually something to the proposition that
each individual is something approximating a divine locus of value,
just our insufficiencies.
And so allowing yourself the benefit of the doubt seems like,
and philosophically appropriate,
but it takes a certain amount of.
It takes a certain amount of courage.
And so we asked people to think,
okay,
well here,
here's a game.
You can have it if you a matter
possibility,
if you're able to progress.
And would that make sense?
Because it's really been something in property.
You're not going to hit it.
So you could have that.
You can hit were you a map?
If you make progress?
The question would be how when you eat properly nouns,
right?
Well,
imagine you started to take care of yourself like something worth taking care
of.
Oh,
so then you could say,
well,
if you could have one you wanted three to five years down the road,
what would it be?
One of the needed,
assuming you were taking care of yourself.
Like if you can think about it like,
do I take care of the Child?
And if you're going to take care of a child,
you wouldn't just grab him or her,
his or her every whim.
That's not care.
So that isn't how you treat yourself.
You have to be more sensible not.
But we could say,
well,
okay,
you get to have what you need three to five years down the road.
What do you want from your family?
If you could put your family together the way you wanted it to be together so
you have what you want it from your father and your mother and your siblings and
your kids,
just hypothetically,
what would that look like?
Probably wouldn't look like the situation where you're all around Thanksgiving
dinner with your hands around each other's necks,
squeezing slowly,
which is the condition that many families at Thanksgiving dinner.
You probably wished for that and it would probably not be for the basket.
Then you might ask,
well,
what would you want from your from your intimate partner,
if you could have what you needed,
what would you want from your career and how you educate yourself?
If you could do that with an auditable way or at least benetrends benefits
panicking now,
how would we take care of your mental and physical health?
What would you do outside of work that would be meaningful and engaging in
productive.